es el esfuerzo por relanzar el diálogo
después de semanas de creciente tensión
el ministro francés de asuntos europeos
y el ministro británico de the break
sheet dicen que han expresado sus
preocupaciones en el asunto de los
derechos de pesca admitiendo que aún
quedan muchas dificultades por superar
reanudarán las conversaciones a
principios de la semana que viene pero
esto no es lo suficientemente pronto
para este pescador en le tréport su
barco lleva meses anclado cambiamos de
barco en 2018 y lo hicimos sin aumentar
nuestra capacidad de pesca y ahora no
nos quieren dar la licencia he estado
pescando a lo largo de la costa inglesa
durante 30 años hemos estado allí
durante años pero aún así dijeron que no
londres ha denegado la licencia a cuatro
buques como el suyo en este puerto de
normandía y han tenido que recurrir a
las aguas costeras francesas esto
aumenta el riesgo de sobreexplotación de
las poblaciones de peces locales dice
este representante sindical si no todos
estos barcos se verán obligados a pescar
en las mismas aguas y como todos irán
por el mismo tipo de peces creará un
desequilibrio en el mercado
este pescadero local también está
soportando la peor parte de la lucha
diplomática ha podido conseguir la mitad
de los tipos de pescado que vende
habitualmente y
espero que mejore a tiempo para navidad
esto es una pérdida de ingresos para
todos es difícil saber qué hacer
la economía marítima local permanece
suspendida es una gota en el océano en
términos del comercio total francia
reino unido pero ni el líder francés y
el británico quieren dar el primer paso
uno tras el break sit y el otro mientras
contempla la reelección en primavera